Brody Jenner just got engaged wishes to
him and yeah I saw him gone maybe a year
and a half ago and he was with Caitlyn
she's gorgeous I'm so happy for him
Kristin Cavallari is now married to Jay
Cutler but she famously dated Brody
Jenner from 2005 to 2006 and the pair
reignited romance rumors during the
final season of the hills
Brody popped the question to his
longtime girlfriend Kaitlin Carter last
week and Kristin couldn't be happier
she's even up for a double date we could
I haven't I mean I saw him but I haven't
talked to him yeah but I love Brody now
and she's so sweet so I'm really really
happy for them it's such an exciting
time and both of their lives and I know
Melinda his mom loves her and so she
must be so excited and so I just think
it's awesome
et caught up with Kristin at the
relaunch bash for her jewelry line
emeralds of I don't think that fashion
has to be intimidating or expensive and
so it's trendy and it's there's classy
pieces that will be in your closet
forever as a mom do you feel like your
jewelry style has changed because you
need maybe simpler Jill Ric's you have
three kids they're probably like mom
grabbing on you want everything yes
luckily my style that comes to jewelry
has always been very simple and
effortless um and so everything that is
in the collection does work well with
having children because there's nothing
to too dangly or too big that they are
gonna pull on and so everything is safe